and so the earlier you can really
identify your purpose and passion and if
the work you're doing is aligning with
that
or if you feel out of alignment then
what can you do to
fill in that gap
[Music]
even better thank you for being on my
show how are you
great well thanks for having me really
really great i'm very excited for this
i'm
you know i i think that it's going to be
fascinating to hear about you know your
journey from from being an accountant
and discovering
yoga and and and now impacting a lot of
people's lives through your
through your presentations your books
you've won multiple awards
and multiple tedx speaker and so i'm
very very excited to mainly get to know
you better and and learn a little bit
about
how you came to where you came to and
and what drove you to those to those
areas
so maybe you can take me all the way
back to your accounting days and
and who's amy vetter and and and what
are you all about
so i would say um all the way back in my
accounting days i didn't know
who amy better was uh so i
had my grandfather was a cpa and
uh from a very young age i was saying i
was going to be a cpa because i
know my grandfather was a cpa friend
everybody
is a certified public accountant
okay which means you're it's for
individuals where you're helping
individuals follow their taxes and
get their money it can be for businesses
um
so a certified public accountant can do
audit where you're auditing companies or
you're doing tax returns
um what could be individuals as well uh
so i like like you just said at 12 years
old how would you know what a cpa
meant right so i basically was was
doing it because i was being told about
it and
that was my path um my journey
so i was very focused on that at the
same time when i was younger
through high school i painted i played
violin and viola
i was very artistic but once
business school and accounting school
and your early career comes up
i had to let those things go because the
total focus
was being successful in the
career that i had chosen and that's one
of the reasons
i say like you know starting out in your
career i don't know that you really know
who you are you think you know who you
are
right you think you know who you want to
be until
you kind of hit these moments in your
career of
you know you achieve certain milestones
that you wanted to achieve
and then you're like wait am i happy
are these the things that i really
wanted uh did i even question
what i wanted explore what i wanted you
know when was that moment when was that
moment for you
when i became a partner in a cpa firm
so that was a kind of a moment i've been
working
toward i was 32. and
when i became partner that was a moment
of like wow
i'm not as happy as i thought it would
be and
i really started doing a lot of
assessment i had started yoga
at that time um mainly because
my after i had had
my second child i gotten sick so i
wasn't allowed to do
many of the types of workouts i was used
to doing so
i was only allowed to do yoga and as a
type a personality that wasn't
an answer i really wanted uh but
i enjoyed i started really enjoying it
but also it was very painful for me like
i go to a yoga class and cry
and not know where that was even coming
from wow but then i'd keep coming back
and uh you know i think there's a lot of
fear
around practices like that because
you're alone with your mind
you know and then it starts taking you
places and and
you have to explore it you become a
researcher of yourself
and that really became the beginning of
my journey i also started
seeing a therapist at that time in my
life
which i think is really important we
often talk about business coaches and
things that are professional but not
necessarily the personal
coaches therapists things that we need
as well from an
for emotional long time i've been saying
that you know people go to the gym three
four times a week to work on their body
but they don't even
they're not even willing to spend an
hour to go talk to a person
to work on them on their inner muscles
right so so i completely
i completely resonate with what you're
saying but going back to this idea of
you know
being a researcher on your own journey
so you're starting this out when you're
when you're having this you know these
doubts as you're entering
a partnership within a large cpa firm
now i'm trying to continue to bring this
back to um
to know young entrepreneurs and
engineers especially in the environment
that i'm in
whether it's at university or in the or
in the workforce in palo alto
things are moving very very fast right
things can get very very hectic 17 18
hour days
the progressions seem to be sort of with
no limit in the sky
as long as you're willing to work very
hard for them so how is it possible for
somebody i mean so first of all
should we be more introspective do you
think earlier on before we hit that
partnership where we where we then start
to
question things or is it okay to work
very very hard to that and then discover
whether it fits us or not
wow there's a lot in that and there's
something you said that i kind of want
to
stop so i i stop and pause on
is you know i've worked in the software
industry in
palo alto silicon valley that whole area
for
many many years and when you say success
comes fast
and people are working really hard
success crashes fast too
and so if you are not taking
time to really get to know who you are
and your whole identity
is the success the success in quotes
right um
you're gonna crash harder if you don't
know yourself
at those times the other thing that's
hard about
those companies and also being an
entrepreneur and so forth and especially
if you have a board and you're taking
investors
is you're replaceable and so
you you really have to have an
understanding of
of what makes you happy besides the work
and how you can define that for yourself
and that's really what
business balance and bliss what uh my
methodology is about
um the the goal being bliss and
bliss as i define it is the maintenance
of happiness
and a lot of times we look for outside
reasons to be happy so if we use your
example
it's getting the next funding or
um you know the new growth customers
that you want
or you know different milestones you
have with the software
but that comes from the outside in
rather than
trying to understand what creates joy
internally in your body and how do you
create that yourself
each day so when things are bad how do
you
come back to that feeling in your body
so it sounds like you look what
the analogy would be that these outside
these external forces are sort of like
drugs that are fitting
off of your of your need to use them to
be happy but
as long as you don't have internal
happiness you're being you're you have
to have those drugs
right because you're not happy yourself
whereas in the idea of
of this bliss of maintaining happiness
it's about how do you generate happiness
through your own inner life with
things that you do have and you don't
need to rely on external external
sources right
yeah you identify what creates happiness
yourself
not relying on other people other things
um where you can cultivate that if you
know and
yoga doesn't have to be the thing
meditation doesn't have to be the thing
you can try and if it works for you
great
it could be running it could be knitting
it could be taking pictures it could
be art listening to music reading
right whatever that is but um
you know or even going back to thinking
about the things that when you were
little
like when i talked about playing violin
and viola and
um uh painting
how do you bring some of those things
back in your life even if you don't have
time to do it
when you go to a concert when do you go
and
go to an art gallery and look at other
people's paintings and
maybe take an art class you know it's
things like that
to get your mind and and
when you release your mind like that you
actually are better at work
because you start coming up with ideas
just by having that time
away right right so then talk to me a
little bit about your experience with
yoga and why
what did yoga do to you that helped you
achieve that
sort of or be on your on your journey to
achieve bliss
well and i think like anything you have
to be ready
um for something like that in your life
you know
and maybe it happens accidentally like
it did for me but then
i kept walking toward it rather than
getting scared off of it
uh you know where it was initially about
exercising
and then it started becoming so much
more that i was able to apply it to my
life
and you know it was really getting
through those hard
moments of number one i was never a
dancer i was never
um anyone that could move their body
like you went into a yoga class and
you're like
wow look at the stuff they're doing and
i had to let that go
of like i am okay if i'm not perfect at
this this is not
what you know is my career i'm doing
this
a little hard for a taipei personality
to do totally
and part of the problem as an adult
whatever you choose whether it's yoga or
something else
um is we expect to be perfect at it the
moment we walk in
versus we know even in our own careers
it took us a long time to be good at
what we're doing and to develop that
expertise so we have to have patience
with ourselves
to learn that new skill and not be hard
on ourselves and that's a really
hard thing to do but when we learn to do
it outside of work it's something we can
bring
into work as well that not only helps
us but helps us as a leader with the
people around us too
right okay and talk to me a little bit
about about the books that you've
written about these subjects
and about these different experiences
yeah so
uh i really came up with business
balance and bliss just to kind of make
it a simplified way to think about
anything that you want to kind of put in
your life because
they're buckets right the business side
is
all the stressors we have anxiety fear
deadlines procrastination you name
what your issue is everybody's got
something
right and we're facing it every day it
could be
other people we work with that we have
trouble with at work
whatever it may be um and it's important
that we offset it so it's business plus
balance equals bliss
and the balance side of this is
mindfulness and collaboration
tools so it's our human toolbox the
things that we
can do ourselves to offset those
stressors so
whether that means better time
management with our calendar
taking breaks during the day to walk or
breathe or listen to music or whatever
we have to do
or learning how to listen better to
others and not
speak over the people that we're working
with you know all of the things that we
can put in place
ourselves without blaming the outside
world
in order to create bliss that
maintenance of happiness
internally by the things that we
can control not expecting other people
to make that shift for us
so why is the business such a big part
of it so i get the i got the balance and
the bliss parts
but why why is b why do you think
business isn't
is an important part of this formula
because i think that many people
if you speak to them they're going to
blame
their job their family members the
co-workers
this is why i don't feel good you know
i've got this really bad boss
or i'm working like crazy hours and i'm
so tired and i'm so stressed out
and then all these things that we say
are the stressors
in our life that's the bucket but
we actually have the opportunity to
control some of these things
if we choose to and not let
the outside world control us and
that's really the empowering thing is
once we start practicing
they're little things but once we start
practicing them
on a day-to-day basis they start
becoming natural and that's
breaking a habit right like if even
just saying every single day to your
co-workers and friends
how stressed you are how much you don't
like your boss or whatever what if you
just stop
saying that how would that change
how you felt each day you know and
maybe change the energy that you were
putting out with the people around you
and to your boss that might
make a little shift you never know you
know so it's it's these
things that we can identify ourselves
that can shift those stressors
so i'd also have to talk a little bit
about impact and and i understand
especially in these worlds a lot of the
coaching that happens one-on-one has a
lot of direct impact on the person that
is
that is learning you might be helping
you know a ceo or an executive
go through their life and and think
through with them how they can
help make these adjustments to to be a
little bit happier
but now i'm wondering on a larger scale
because you've given you've given
countless talks and keynotes and tedx
presentations
and and so many different people were
impacted by them is there a way for you
to know
to to know the impact that you're having
on them or how to even
resonate with with a large crowd as
you're talking about these big ideas
where every person is sort of trying to
adjust it into their own life
well i think the way you know my style
is
telling some of my own stories so that
people can internalize
that themselves you know so when
i'm authentic and and vulnerable and
telling things that
you know aren't necessarily great
stories about myself or when i had hard
times
other people can as well and i think
part
of the world problem right is
we only see the outside of people and so
people can make assumptions all day long
about me or you
and and say oh you know their life's
been perfect or
you know things just come easy for them
and when they
learn the stories behind the person then
you become more real
and it's no different when you go back
in the workplace and instead of
looking at everyone from the outside how
could you get to know someone from a
more human standpoint
and from a speaking perspective
you know i can't know every single
person
that i make an impact with but what i do
know is
the people that come and talk to me or
message me after
or that end up wanting to take the
you know i have an online learning
program that helps them actually
implement this in their life so people
that want to take those actions
but i've seen many people you know post
the things that they went back and
started playing guitar again or painting
again
or doing these things because they got
inspired
to go do it and that is what keeps my
fire going because i'm like okay then
what i'm doing is worth it you know that
it's helping others but it has to come
from
i think a very authentic place it's not
that the goal is um
the career and i think that's the big
shift after your 30s
it's about purpose and if
you're younger um and
you don't have purpose behind what
you're doing it can become very
empty and so the earlier you can really
identify your purpose and passion and if
the work you're doing is aligning with
that
or if you feel out of alignment then
what can you do
to fill in that gap right so what is one
tangible thing that i can take with me
as i go into you know the office uh
tomorrow and
and try to implement you know some of
this more well-rounded balanced
thinking and more in internal
introspection what what can i what can
and should i do
throughout my day or throughout my week
to make it a little bit easier for me
well and many aren't going into offices
right now and
we're right now i mean
and so forth so i think what's really
important is how
you man your calendar um first off so
uh i'm really a big believer that a
meeting does not have to be 30 minutes
it can be 25 or instead of an hour 50
minutes so you can build in breaks
in between meetings to decide what you
want to do
on those breaks and i call it at least
taking two minutes
to either meditate you know
take get up walk around do some
stretches
listen to music whatever you need to do
so that
you don't leave one meeting
and then let that snowball into the next
meeting
and then by the end of the day you're so
stressed out or frustrated you don't
even know
if the frustration is from that person
or if it's just the snowballing from the
day
totally and i can imagine that now
during covert that everything is so
quick and
you know right after this meeting i go
and i answer all these messages
with one minute with the one minute i
have before joining the next zoom call
yeah so it's a little bit crazy part of
your job
which part of your job do you enjoy most
is it the writing the
speaking the meeting the online learning
what is it i love what i do
i don't i don't have uh i mean i i
speaking i would say obviously is the
number one
thing i'd love to do because i love the
light bulbs going on and and you can see
the impact
you know immediately where some of the
others is a longer
term thing but i i i really love
interacting with people so
most of my job is that okay amy first of
all i want to thank you for being so
generous with your time and for being on
the show
i truly appreciate it i know how busy
you are and and
the last question that i want to ask the
most important one and fun one
are three words that you would use to
describe yourself and and why those
three specific words
um i know you gave me until the end so
i'm a mother
um okay first off i'm very proud of the
two boys i have that are teenagers
um uh
confidence that i i think that it has
helped me
a great deal um
[Music]
to be able to take on risks and
opportunities
and go through failures as well when
needed and go through the hard times
and i would say loyal um to the people
that have been good to me
back like that i have very long term
relationships and even new people like
you know i i think anyone that
is in that circle of trust
um you know we have very strong deep
relationships
i love it amy thank you very very much i
truly appreciate it
and continue to making a positive impact
on people thank you very much
thank you